[Music]
songwriting is the greatest joy that i
have in my life it's the favorite my
favorite element of what i do
taking it in and being grateful every
day for the fact that i get to write
songs for a living because a lot of
people write songs
and it doesn't get to be
what keeps their lights on and for me
to be able to be one of those people i
never
forget how lucky i am
with anything you know distance makes
the heart go fonder so having that
distance from my fans for the longest
i've ever had since i was 12 years old
having almost two years separated from
me and my audience
the pandemic kind of reunited and and
just lit that that spark again for me
for the gratitude that i have for being
able to be a live musician first i think
i've had
in a way
this amazing gift that my audience
grew up with me
it's very different than the
relationship that i have with the public
or the press or the media or their
perception of me but it's really stayed
grounded
in
the really unique relationship that i
have with my fans and with my audience
because a lot of us were the same age
the people that watched
my show were my same age
[Music]
i'm very passionate about
a lot of things especially
different forms of creativity and
artistry i never sign or say i'll
collaborate with someone that i don't
have the capacity to actually give them
what they deserve which is my full focus
my attention and my ideas and when i'm
depleted i don't have as good of ideas
right now a focus of mine is my
collaboration that i have with gucci it
was just very natural for me i i respect
gucci as a brand
i love what they're doing
philanthropically we actually shared a
lot of the same team members uh from
happy hippie and gucci without even
knowing we were ever gonna partner up so
we already we align on our values and
our morals
and then also making beautiful clothes
[Music]
happy hippie
is my purpose i think the activism
and artistry they're really one i think
artists come with a message
and
my message was
justice
equality celebration of individuality
and it's been a beautiful evolution not
just
to watch but as
you know the founder of happy hippie to
see how much process we've had in the
last five years not just happy hippie
but it kind of seems
globally that the conversation
of love
acceptance justice equality
that is the topic right now and it's
just really beautiful to be alive and
experience this new kind of
revolutionary time that we're all living
in feels like there's a nice shift
happening where
people may not completely change their
mind but their mind is open and that's
really
the way that you can get in there with
your own message
[Music]
you